hey guys my name is Jesse there's a 29th
of September and you're watching games
but needs first up dice has revealed
more details about battlefield ones
single-player campaign the official
battlefield website has been updated
with descriptions for five so-called war
stories the stories are titled friends
in high places nothing is written avanti
subway and the runner friends in high
places will see you play as a British
pilot through intense dogfights
unexpected encounters and a story of
friendship well the runner will have you
take on the role of an Anzac messenger
who most deliver life-or-death messages
on the battlefield near the Gallipoli
landing site battlefield one launches on
October 21 but you can play a portion of
the game including a piece of the
through mud and blood war story on
october 13 if you're an EA or origin
access member in avenues that as an my
producer making qpo noises the Brazilian
ratings board may have leaked a bullet
storm HD remaster according to the page
on the ratings board website to the
remaster will be titled bought storm
full clip edition and will released in
2017 on xbox one ps4 and PC this isn't
too surprising as you may remember the
rerelease was sort of leak to the three
after USBs containing screenshots of the
game were given to media outlets what is
surprising though is that it looks like
the original publisher EA is not
involved in the full clip edition with
borderlands develop the gearbox being
listed as the game's publish up
Bulletstorm was originally released in
2009 for 360 PC and ps3 it's an
over-the-top violent crash stylish
first-person shooter that featured a
skill-shot system that rewarded place
for inventive killed finally Microsoft
has revealed three new games that are
coming to Xbox one drew backwards
compatibility according to the official
Xbox UK twitter account lost odyssey toy
story 3 and go on gay are all available
to play now an xbox one through
backwards compatibility toy story 3 is a
platformer unsurprisingly based on the
movie of the same name while the one I'm
probably pronouncing wrong is a port of
a verdict
scrolling shoot-'em-up lost odyssey is a
JRPG by the creator of Final Fantasy you
can play HIVs by chucking your physical
360 copies into your xbox one or you can
download the digital versions let me
know your thoughts on today's story head
to gamespot for nissan time for two and
just me and i'll have my top five
stories of the whole week already here
tomorrow